wir werden es nicht alle mitgekriegt
haben aber wir alle werden zeuge einer
revolution jahre lang haben wir hier in
der heute-show gelästert über die
schnarchen deutsche digitalisierung aber
jetzt beginnt die zukunft freunde bisher
mussten junge eltern innerhalb der
ersten woche nach geburt ihres babys
persönlich aufs amt um den neuen
menschen dort anzumelden weil sonst ist
es ja gar kein mensch da haben sich also
erschöpfte mütter mit säugling im arm
und teilweise noch heraushängen der
nabelschnur
zur behörde geschleppt und das geht nun
plötzlich also bald also vielleicht und
nur wenige jahrzehnte nach erfindung des
internets online
wir wollen einen digitalen start der
konsequent aus der perspektive
und das ist mir persönlich sehr wichtig
der bürgerinnen und bürger
gedacht denken doch auch an die bürger
denken das ist nicht mehr mein land
meine damen und herren wahnsinn ja ab
januar funktioniert die zulassungsstelle
für deutsche babys angeblich digital
läuft dann wahrscheinlich so erst mal
müssen sie biometrische fotos vom baby
machen dann ein ganzkörper scanner vom
baby anschließend muss das baby beweisen
es kein roboter ist also alle bilder
markieren auf den ampeln zu sehen sind
und schließlich lädt der papa noch ein
notariell beglaubigtes sexvideo der
zeugung hoch wer hat denn sonst hätte
das ja jeder sein können
ab januar also wenn sie gerade schwanger
sind es lohnt sich das baby noch ein
bisschen länger drin zu halten
immerhin die ampel fängt wenigstens mal
an das so genannte online zugangs gesetz
von 2017 auch umzusetzen bis ende dieses
jahres also bis ende 22 sollte man knapp
600 verwaltungsdienstleistungen online
erledigen können so der plan so wie viel
davon läuft stand heute bereits
papierlos es sind insgesamt 15 prozent
meine damen und herren das sind mehr als
trotzdem fürchte ich 100 prozent bis
ende 2022 das wird knapp ja ja nancy
faeser unsere in die ministerin sagt
inzwischen frühestens 2025 als sie
selber ausgerechnet mit ihrem abacus
abgesehen davon muss ja digitale
verwaltung gar nicht immer so digital
sein die bürger haben den eindruck ist
dass digital aber wenn die dann ihre
digitale eingabe gemacht haben druck die
verwaltung des aus und da geht es in
umlauf mappen weiter zu den kolleginnen
kollegen
umlauf mappe eines der schönsten
deutschen worte überhaupt oder reine
poesie ich mache mir also online einen
termin und muss dann trotzdem persönlich
im amt an tanzen wie unter kaiservilla
mein gott warum geht das so schleppend
selten wird eine antwort sie so wenig
überrascht haben wegen föderalismus
unter anderem jede kommune darf mit
ihrer eigenen software vor sich hin
mucke aber nicht mehr lange denn das
online zugangs gesetz verspricht eine
einheitliche digitale verwaltung und die
sie dann tatsächlich so aus ist ja ich
glaube ich selbst erklärend oder
so sieht es wahrscheinlich im kopf von
karl lauterbach aus
das hier ist tatsächlich eine offizielle
übersicht der sogenannten e government
offensive ich hoffe sie haben
mitgeschrieben das ist alles klausur
relevant meine damen und herren
natürlich gibt es in deutschland auch
schon einzelne vorzeige städte in denen
ich meinen rauhaardackel per app
anmelden kann aber in den meisten
deutschen ämtern zieht man dem immer
noch eine warte marke es ist ja so dass
er drankommt ist ausgestorben aber gut
ich nehme an andere länder stellen sich
da auch ähnlich druckern oder wo steht
deutschland aktuell platz 22 von 27 in
der eu bei den online behörden diensten
an 61 im un index zur digitalen teilhabe
der bürger hinter armenien und oman
das peinlich peinlich also peinlich für
armenien und oman zusammen mit uns
genannt zu
1,4 milliarden euro würde uns die
digitalisierung der verwaltung jährlich
sparen jedes jahr die dänen die doofen
streber erledigen schon 90 prozent ihrer
behördengänge online in estland kann man
online wählen bei uns hat auch die ampel
leider auf ein eigenes digital
ministerium verzichtet den job macht
volker wissing so nebenbei mein gott toi
toi toi aber wenn es einer schafft dann
der mit den schönen essen später darauf
installieren dabei haben wir deutschen
so viele technische innovationen
angeschoben mit denen dann andere aber
später erfolgreich war die atombombe zum
beispiel oder oder oder hier die
computermaus kein witz die computermaus
haben wir erfunden also er hier das ist
also die computer muss wir haben sie
damals genannt rks 100 wohl kugel
störung 100 großartig oder wall kugeln
steuerung als ich leider nie
durchgesetzt dabei hätte das so viel
schöner geklungen die sendung mit der
holzkugel steuerung
bringt nancy faeser die digitalisierung
unserer behörden endlich voran
hoffentlich nicht meint professor
dietmar wischmeyer analoger historiker
an der honigtau bunsenbrenner
fachhochschule braunschweig ruhe wird
der herrschaften der furor digital ist
also die digitale zerstörung bedroht
eins der größten kulturdenkmäler der
geschichte das deutsche amt dort wo sich
analoge reptilien respektive beamte in
gelebter nahtoderfahrung gegenseitig im
wege stehen wir alle sind aufgerufen
dieses erbe für die menschheit zu retten
schon jetzt kommen besucher aus aller
welt um in der abgeschiedenheit eines
deutschen funk los einkehr zu halten
esten letten und südkoreaner schnüffeln
verzückt an den ausdünstungen von
matrizen druckern amerikaner machen in
germany wie einst ihre ur großväter eine
kopie ihres nackten hintern ganz
deutschland ist für sie erinnerungen an
eine anderswo längst versunkene kultur
wir wollen uns heute die elektronische
rechenmaschine ansehen wie hier im haus
der senator für inneres aufgestelltes
kontaktgruppe habe mich zu begrüßen sie
sind sozusagen der herren bei diesen
zauberkasten
uralter aufnahmen aus dem jahr 2017
sauber kasten dieser mann so
taschenrechner die schon damals die
moderne erahnen doch ältere beamte
erinnern sich sogar noch an die
einführung des dezimalsystem ce- und die
anschaffung des ersten
dampfgetriebenen bleistifte anspitzer
bei der wahl in berlin letztes jahr oder
sogar von die zeitenwende geprobt im
übergang zum papierlosen büro chaos vor
den wahllokalen lange warteschlangen
fehlende unterlagen und genervte
berliner ankamen sie haben gesagt dass
es
gibt einfach keine zettel mehr oder wo
ich gesagt nee ich könnte nach hause
gehen ist ein karneval z blöderweise
fand der großversuch bei einer
bundestagswahl statt die jetzt in der
hälfte der wahlkreise eventuell
wiederholt werden muss heißt im analogen
deutschland könnte armin laschet doch
noch kanzler werden oder rudolf
scharping wer weiß wie weit der murks
zurückreicht trotz alledem ist für
ältere der behördengang oft der einzige
sozialkontakt sollen wir das alles
aufgeben für einen digitalen hokuspokus
ist der schnellhefter an sich nicht
längst teil unserer identität diese
antimaterie die auf bollerwagen über
flure geschoben wird sie von selbst
zerfällt mal geht es um die
baugenehmigung für einen internationalen
flughafen mal um die bewilligung eines
zweiten wellensittich für
grundsicherungsempfänger
ein papier gewordenes überraschungsei
wie wunderbar und jetzt hoffen wir
gemeinsam auf die aussendung des
heiligen geistes an pfingsten der kommt
garantiert an denn im gegensatz zu
deutschland hat gott bluetooth
[Applaus]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher